aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
prévention des enlèvements d'enfants et
pour souligner un peu cette journée on a
pensé inviter pina arcamone directrice
générale de la connaissez bien du réseau
enfant retour québec bonjour madame
arcamone alors des journées comme ça
aujourd'hui une journée mondiale tout
comme des campagnes de prévention de
sensibilisation est encore très très
utile aujourd'hui en 2019 si je vous dis
même encore plus on ne fera jamais assez
de prévention on ne fera jamais assez de
campagne de sensibilisation pour
prévenir les disparitions d'enfants
je vais vous mettre en contact en 2018
selon la grc pour le québec on a les
crocs de police ont enregistré 5925
signalement de disparition
exactement dont il y avait c'était une
baisse comparé à l'année 2010 est donc
c'est encourageant de voir que les
chiffres ont baissé un peu mais il
demeure quand même que tout près de 6000
jeunes ont été signalées comme étant
portées disparues et on convient que
c'est le pire cauchemar une famille et
des jeunes dont leur vie pour être
compromise est-ce qu'on a des chiffres
pour cette année au nom pas encore le
bilan en fin d'examen donc près de 6000
enfants qui sont portées disparues pour
la plupart sont des fugues exactement
jusqu'à 90% de ces signalements
représentent des jeunes en fugue et au
niveau de l'enlèvement
l'enlèvement la plus courante c'est un
élément qui est commis par les membres
de la famille de ce qu'on appelle
enlèvement parental à chaque année il y
a peut être une centaine de dossiers à
travers le canada dont 30 40 qui
proviennent aussi du québec
il est heureusement qu'elle enlèvement
criminel demeure un phénomène rare mais
par contre le danger est toujours là on
l'a vécu le 31 juillet en 2007 lorsque
c'est du cac provencher a été enlevé c
est je pense que cette journée lui
dédier ça nous rappelle que les enfants
sont vulnérables quand même si c'est un
événement qui est extrêmement rare le il
ya un vrai danger pour nos jeunes donc
on doit vraiment les outiller à l'année
longue
année après année à reconnaître des
stations à l'isq surtout de lisibilité
et de se confier à des personnes en qui
ils ont confiance
vous avez parlé de 80 ch et d
il ya plusieurs corps qui ne sont pas
résolues les politiques et gardons bien
sûr ces dossiers ouverts on s'est vus
vous étiez sur ce plateau là au mois de
mai on parlait de tous les efforts
étaient faits dans le cadre du mois de
mai il y avait un partenariat également
que vous aviez signé qui vous permettra
en fait de mettre en prétendant lumière
en tout cas de
montrer des cas qui sont toujours non
résolu est ce que ça vous a permis ce
d'avant davantage d'informations ce qui
est des nouvelles bien sûr quelques
dossiers je vous dirais que oui
sa garde espoir pour les familles aussi
on veut leur rappellent que leur enfant
n'est pas oublié mais nous avons vu des
signalements que nous avons transmis au
corps de police pour que cette
information puisse être validée alors
ses campagnes où ces partenariats nous
permet vraiment de donner une belle
visibilité aux enfants qui manquent à
l'appel
et je vais vous dire que ces campagnes
nous permettent de retrouver ses enfants
aujourd'hui et on pense aussi par les
réseaux sociaux qui nous aide vraiment à
circuler les informations apportées
immédiat à la famille mais de rejoindre
le jeune avec un message d'espoir aussi
est de venir en aide le plus rapidement
possible donc une occasion de rappeler
c'est comme de jeunes enfants donc de
jeunes disparus non résolus mais
également de prévenir enlèvement aux
disparitions rapidement quelques
secondes
l'application que vous avez mis en place
certains signes signal on peut la
télécharger directement à partir du site
web du réseau enfants retour aller
disponible en anglais en français et une
famille peut ainsi que jusqu'à cinq
enfants sur cette application donc on a
toutes les informations photo photo
description ou quoi parler ce mois-là
rapidement et exactement donc vous
l'avez à la portée de la main c'est la
période des vacances tout le monde
trinque son téléphone qui lui a donc
emmené le assurez vous d'avoir cette
information a à date ça pourrait
vraiment faire la différence entre
retrouver un enfant rapidement et une
recherche qui pourrait se prolonger
malheureusement ce qu'on sait qu'en cas
de séparation chaque minute chaque heure
comment maintenir kaman merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui vous